um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
foreign
yet
um
thank you so much
prime minister dia albin thank you very
much first of all uh to receive me here
in pristina in this beautiful
kindergarten
and um to to see what we've done
together this is a living symbol of the
joint corporation that we see here
to the benefit of the children and it's
not just
a new building but it's an investment in
our children's education our children's
well-being and it was heartwarming and
really
impressive to see
how you fill this kindergarten with life
and it is a symbol for the future
that we are building together
and we want a future where kosovo and
all the western balkans are part of the
european union that's what we're working
for
it's a long way to go we've come a long
way we've made a lot of progress we
never lose sight of the goal that is all
western balkans kosovo part of the
european union that's what we want and i
think
we owe it to the children that we've
seen here that we've met here in the
kindergarten we owe it to the children
because it's their future and we want
them to have a european future indeed as
you said based on values that's how the
european union has been funded founded
and
living and thriving on economic success
so topics we've been discussing together
we're already partnering as you
mentioned here albin in the fight
against the pandemic
our joint priorities are clear we want
to speed up vaccination in kosovo
and we want to ensure a lasting a
sustainable economic recovery
perhaps a few words first of all on
vaccination
indeed team europe has donated over 387
000 vaccine doses to kosovo so far in
addition to vaccines from covax and more
vaccine doses will be coming
now we know that vaccine doses are
important but much more important is
vaccination
so that people get vaccinated that saves
lives and it is so important that you
protect yourself but you also protect
your beloved ones what we do not want is
a pandemic of the unvaccinated with all
the risks of variance therefore let's
step up the efforts to increase
the level of vaccination i commend you
for the achievements you have already
indeed this is respectable but of course
we all know same goes for the european
union we still have to step up with a
delta variant um that
the amount of vaccinations
on the recovery
um the european union has already
invested significantly
to help address the emergency of the
crisis we mobilized 3.3 billion euro for
support for the region
kosovo has received 168 million euros in
grants and financing just to deal with
immediate consequences
of the pandemic
so we know the topic it's vital medical
supplies but it is also the wider
regional economic recovery package or
support for the health care system which
is so much needed
now
having done that and having said that
let's look forward to a more strategic
investment
it is about ensuring a lasting recovery
in kosovo
because just like in the european union
the people of kosovo and especially the
children we have seen deserve a greener
they deserve a more digital more
prosperous future with plenty of
opportunities to succeed you told me
that kosovo is a country of of
entrepreneurs and of
people with a lot of entrepreneurship
you should really benefit from that with
quality
well-paid jobs that are so important
and this is what the economic and
investment plan for the western balkan
is all about
we have put 9 billion euros on the table
and what we need now and the process has
already started a quality mature project
that you design
you'd propose so it's a kosovo owned and
designed process
with that we can leverage up to 20
billion euro more 20 billion euro more
in investment
the good news is this year if you will
look at this year the plan has already
allocated 500 million euros
and i'm very pleased to announce that we
will propose an additional 600 million
euro still for this year so let's join
forces that this plan is a success and i
thank you for the long list of projects
you have given me in our bilateral talk
there's a lot of good work to do let me
just highlight one or two of those
projects there is for example
the support to the peace highway
linking prishtina and nish in serbia i
think an important symbolic project and
another example we is that we can
support the ongoing works
for the last section of railroad 10
and very important for you a waste water
treatment plant in pristina we have been
discussing that in our bilateral meeting
so the economic and investment plan will
bring growth and it will bring jobs to
the region
but it is also crucial to support the
integration within the regions
all six partners must move forward
quickly on the common regional market
this is a pre-condition for growth
and
for a strong economic development and it
is key to get the maximal benefit from
the economic and investment plan and to
progress in the european integration
process
and perhaps a few words on this
it is of course a topic that we
discussed at length
i've been and
it is so important that we move forward
along the european path it is vital that
kosovo and serbia normalize their
relations we've been discussing the
issues
i must say i'm very concerned about the
current crisis
it is important to de-escalate and to
return to the negotiation table to find
a sustainable solution
and the only way to do that is the eu
facilitated dialogue that is the only
platform to resolve the current crisis
we will stay in touch
we've discussed that because i want to
see kosovo progress
and this is only possible through
cooperation so let's work together on
that
finally
it is also crucial that kosovo continues
to consolidate the work on the fight
against corruption and organized crime i
really commend you
for the progress and the enormous amount
of work you have hard work you've
invested in that i commend you for that
and we fully support your government's
commitment move forward on reforms also
in the judiciary
these are far-reaching judicial reforms
they must be done in full respect of
international and european standards i
know that you're very committed to that
this is very good because there is still
work to do but with this
uh prime minister dear albin let me tell
you how much i'm looking forward not
only having had the meeting here with
you but also next week to meet you again
at the western balkan summit in slovenia
there we have also a lot of progress and
deliverables to discuss
there's one last point
i want you i want kosovo to fully take
part in the conference on the future of
europe
because kosovo has an important
contribution to make
and we want to hear the voice of the
people we want to hear the voice of
those who want to shape the future for
europe so we want you also
in the conference on the future of
europe because that's where you belong
to thank you
for president i have
two questions for you the first one is
on the
kosovo serbia border crisis
uh are you concerned with the russian
presence in the
in the north of kosova i mean in the
border between the two countries
and
do you hope that the today's meeting in
the brussels is going to
give a result to solve this
crisis and my second question is on the
eu integrational process as you may know
you're visiting today the most isolated
country and nation on europe soil so
you do met with president michelle often
uh do you have any sign that the council
is going to move forward
and
of course being
a european union member do you think
that this is going to happen
one year one day or it's just a
good dream
thank you founded
first of all um on
the
issues we see at the moment being at the
border
let me reflect on that
at first and i as we speak we have
indeed
negotiators in brussels discussing these
issues and i hope they come with a
strong mandate to negotiate because
that's the best way
to resolve the problems and to move
forward in general
i am deeply convinced that it is so
important to de-escalate and to go back
to a dialogue that is constructive why
do i say this
because
i come from a country and i come from
a european union that has experienced
over since more than 70 years
what it means to overcome disputes and i
come from a country that brought world
war ii to the globe and that is
responsible for the holocaust so i know
what it means
that
how important it is
that we work together
we do trade together we started with the
trade in coal and steel at the very
beginning of the european union by that
slowly but surely we forged
friendship
and friendship created trust
and friendship created the reliability
that we can work together for the future
and over time
this brought us to a process that we
understood with all the difficulties in
the past which should not be forgotten
which should be remembered
because they also are warning signs and
it is also in respect to those who lost
their lives that we should remember the
past but that we are able to look
towards the future
in a way
that we
from a point of friendship and
cooperation are able to overcome the
difficulties this finally leads to
reconciliation that is so necessary
why am i addressing that because these
are also
matters or questions of time
to be invested i know that there is
impatience to move forward and this i
honor that i highly respect that and
it's a wonderful sign of trust in the
european union which i really cherish
and value high
so let's take that impatience and put it
into a constructive work forward that
is so important for the region
and yes it is important it is necessary
and it's wonderful to have dreams
in my political life
i always had dreams
and by following up these dreams
i my experience is that you make a
change
that you
you are effective that you move forward
and yet you come closer to your dream so
i share the dreams of the region you
know that i'm a staunch supporter of uh
the process of enlargement i want the
western balkans by our side that's where
you belong we want you we need you
this is a dream yes but it's worth to
work for it because every achievement
every historic achievement started with
a dream started with dedication and
that's the reason why i came here why i
am here i want to listen to you
i want to learn more about the region so
that next week at the summit and in the
following months and years we have a
solid basis of trust and friendship on
which we can work on
i have no translation on my ear
right now
yeah it's just that i get an idea from
the answer perhaps
that's fine that's fine as long as i get
it
is
um
foreign
if you listen carefully
to the discussion
here and in the past days
i think this is a proof in itself how
important it is
to speak together about finding a
solution and that will be exactly my
message tonight in serbia you can rely
on that and tomorrow in the press
conference in serbia too
dear albin
i was carefully listening to and if i
may quote
you open the door
in a very constructive way
when you say i'm ready to accept a new
solution that is inclusive reciprocity
and comprehensive i hope i quoted you
correctly
and this openness we should take
go to the
eu dialogue eu facilitated dialogue
open is from the other side too because
we understand it's not only a question
of license plates we all know that it's
more it's a question how this region
will move forward and whether we're
going to be able to go together the path
to more integration
and
towards our european values here i also
want to say that investment comes with
respecting of the european values you
also can rely on that because the
european values this is what binds us
this is what the foundation of the
european union and our close cooperation
is
the single market is important economy
is important for prosperity but it is
all nothing if you don't have the values
and the respect for the values and
therefore as we will be a strong
advocate and guardian of the european
value and you can
rely on that
foreign
them
foreign
you